what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this
is unwaxed we're going shopping with
sophia and sistine stallone do we just
become best friends
yup
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome you cannot
take my intro sistine
take it away thank you hello everybody
and welcome back to another episode of
the unwax podcast with your favorite
sisters
sophia and sistine you guys i've missed
you i feel like
missing a week of recording kind of made
me sad
i felt really lazy for not doing it even
though it's been
actually very chaotic and i'm sorry for
letting everyone down
on letting everyone know beforehand that
we were not doing an episode this past
week
but yeah but i missed you guys how are
you how are you
how you feeling how are you feeling
steam
i'm a little self-conscious why i'm
trying something new here
give me a second let me put them on
do you like my glasses you look like
harry potter
a little bit i just are they real
no they're not real i this is i don't i
think that's a little weird
can i tell you something when i was
younger
first and foremost i think if you have
bad eyesight and you wear
glasses 10 out of 10. when i was younger
i always wanted to have bad eyesight
because i wanted to wear glasses
now unfortunately i was blessed with
perfect sight
so i okay so i am now wearing
non-prescription glasses
and you're making fun of me sistine with
someone
is it that bad it's a it's cute it's
just like it's i
i don't know you know i've had glasses
because i actually have
horrible eyesight oh brag a bit more
sophia
no but i i wish i didn't have bad
eyesight i wish i could just
not wear my contacts every single
morning and get dry eyes from them
i wish i didn't have to wear glasses
every single morning
look at the bright side of it you look
like a sexy little secretary in there is
that how you feel you don't have to wear
eye makeup
because the glasses just hide it that
makes they're see-through what are you
talking about yeah but you know
my eyeliner's a bit wonky today so it
kind of fixes it covers it up
okay you know what fine keep them on
she's gonna leave them you can let us
know if she looks like a sexy librarian
i guarantee i'm going to watch this
footage back and say why would you let
me wear these things
[Applause]
okay well let's move on we have a lot
a lot to catch up with yeah we really do
the reason why we missed
last week's episode was because sophia
and i finally moved back to la full time
by florida it's been a great almost six
months of us being there
but now we're going to be here
permanently
really you were saying the same thing to
me the other day
the weather everyone's okay the weather
in la is great
or do you just miss a boy in florida i
don't miss
anybody i have no boys in florida i
don't know what you're talking about
fair enough no but it's like i feel like
the air quality
is not as good i love humidity i know
people don't like humidity but i love it
okay and it's just so no things are not
as open
as they are in florida i will say this
i've been
very bored being back in l.a really
i think i was so productive in florida i
had things going on my schedule was busy
and now i'm trying to you know you've
hit boredom when you try to do things
for yourself
that just take up time during the day
yeah you know what i mean
like we've gone to a lot of workout
classes lately we've gotten to a lot
of workouts just to kill time i can't
move my limbs right now
yes genuinely if anyone can see i have a
cut on my arm from one time
boxing i know it's just that was my goal
it doesn't happen that way
we're making lunch plans with people we
typically would never see
never see never see but hey i started
taking up italian
i cannot stress enough how many times
me no no i've just heard you in the
kitchen saying little italian phrases
and you leave your booklet everywhere
where you write down these italian words
what's
i have a question why are you learning
italian we're not going to italy anytime
soon i don't think you're planning on
moving there
you're not dating an italian kid it sort
of just goes back to the glasses i feel
like everything in my life
is revolving around these glasses i look
smarter therefore i should know another
language is this
new year new me and this is you you're
trying to wear glasses and be italian
i you know what it is do you remember we
had rob dylan
a few episodes back yeah and he was just
saying all of these things that sort of
made me feel bad that i was doing
nothing with my life
and that i cannot commit to anything and
that i quit on things easily
well i thought cysteine do you think
that you can commit to something for
more than two weeks without quitting
and i said i think i can and i'm on week
four
of learning as well good that's more
consistent than
anything since i've been home but you
know what was funny
you mentioned something that you got in
the email the other day
oh my god i wanted to bring up because i
think a lot of people feel this way when
they're graduates of any school well
okay
if you this is my psa if you attend
any sort of reunion you're weird
you think that's a weird thing to do
thank you for coming to my ted talk
yes i do and first of all this email was
for
a reunion from my middle school why
would i ever want to see those kids
again first of all i was a
weirdo weirdo we can get into all the
weird things we did in middle school but
like i don't want to see these kids
i don't well this was a middle school
one yes uh
our middle school was weird i get
college college is fine well assistant
the reason why our middle school was
weird was we had 10 kids a class
so what do you just do in a reunion with
10 kids in there that's so true
really like what do you do at least with
like big high schools you can kind of
distract yourself and probably hide
but i just like but die you can't but
would you go to a high school or any
sort of reunion
yeah i don't want to see these kids i
would only go to a high school reunion
until i know that i've peaked
i can't go when i have nothing going on
hold up you're telling me
you would only attend a reunion when you
are just
at your best and you want to show
everyone how good you're doing
you want to attend a reunion where
you're at your lowest
and you look horrible but everyone else
is good we're going for the wrong
reasons right now
you're supposed to reunite no i want to
brag i want to go into a group
of people and be like yeah i have that
great husband yep i have that
stellar job my body is banging after
three kids
you would you would no i wouldn't you
wouldn't what would you do there then
talk to people
not even attend not even attend that's
what i would do
i want to talk about something a little
bit serious
you know how i've always felt i know
we're so all over the map with this
intro but i've just missed talking to
you guys so much i know
i just love it um
you know i always feel about people
watching me
through camera devices and in the
computer and the iphone yeah
i will go to such extremes that say if
i'm working out and i'm doing a core
exercise and my phone is facing up i
will put a towel on top of it because i
genuinely think
people are watching me all of the time
you're not that important to watch
first of all rude second of all
one in four cameras get hacked so those
numbers
don't love them you're the wonderful all
right so why are you getting into this
rabbit hole of people stalking you
so i was on reddit right really late the
other night and i was just
deep diving deep diving and i read
some pretty scary things and
do with this information what you will
but i just thought you know
the unwaxes should be aware no idea
so i recently found out someone told me
oh did you know that siri
and i know i'm gonna say this and
everyone's gonna be like no [ __ ] sistine
no [ __ ] but siri spelled backwards is
iris
right so then i go no [ __ ] so what's
yeah no i am aware so then i so then i
start researching all right
tell me of this theory tell me if you
believe it right
iphone break it down i
like your eyeball phone equals
illuminati phone system where is this
going siri
spelled backwards is iris that is a part
of the eye
correct right stay with me apple is
illuminati
they're watching you hold on
i have another one are you ready no
so siri spilled backwards so i got you
know i
i pulled up another one because sophia
is very into greek mythology
and i thought the first one wouldn't
hook you but i think this one i think
this one
so siri spelled backwards is iris yeah
iris is the name of a messenger between
gods and humans in greek mythology
just saying but wait no no but isn't
siri's whole point is communication
between technology and humans because
you see siri i need help with
yes so so that's cool
if that's why they chose it you're
missing
the first one was creepier i mean the
first one kind of got a little bit
it's like is there more to this no okay
what else did you want a book report
what do you mean you're wearing glasses
so maybe this is the glasses
you thought i came more prepared today
the glasses you came in really hot i
mean
honestly pretty good that's like a
conspiracy theory that we should
probably dive into one of these days
yeah you know i just feel like forget it
let's move on
okay wait this is i liked it i liked it
thanks
um cece and i want to talk about this
because
i don't know if anyone else has felt
this way when they meet this certain
thing oh god i'm so suspicious no it
sounds weird but
i want to get into babies so
cece and i went to lunch yesterday with
one of our good friends and he just had
a baby
with his wife and i think she's 10
months old and he's like i really want
you to meet her you guys are clear
you're good code free like let's go
i i was scared to i mean i was scared
that she was gonna hand me the baby and
i'd drop it i was gonna be probably
annoyed because sometimes when i hear a
kid cry it really annoys me or i hate
when i pick up a child and it starts
crying
because if a baby hates you that means
you're just an unlikable person bad
person
i heard babies another theory babies
really can read humans so if a baby
starts crying
that they just know that you're not a
good person no it's not that the baby
might be in
a small no i agree with you it's not
that the baby could be maybe an [ __ ]
but it's that you're the [ __ ] because
the baby's an [ __ ]
yeah exactly so we met the baby
i fell in love i fell
in love and this is the freakiest part i
didn't want
kids or anything and then i saw this
baby and i
wanted it not in the creepy connection
but like i
you went into full mommy maternal mode
and i was just
enjoying my fries well this baby was
like looking at me and i just kept
i was having a staring worth it and then
she handed the baby to me
and it just sunk in my arms it was
laughing with me or
at me but it's cute regardless either or
and then i just i thought what was
concerning for me is the entire ride
home
and following the morning you kept
saying that you are ready to be a mom oh
yeah a hundred times you are 24 years
old
where do you get off well the crazy
thing is is i've been saying i don't
want a kid for so long i was i don't
want one until i'm 35 like i just want
to figure out my career
and now i'm like you know 25 is
i gotta have a quarter life crisis here
maybe that's my quarter life crisis i
need a kid
can you find me a student first we need
the dude
first step number one but we remember
how chris medina the psychic came on and
said that you'd have the
kid first he said that remember i always
oh no you said he said you get married
first
should we bring the psychic back on and
see who's gonna get pregnant first if he
says that
i'm gonna get pregnant first but you get
married first
plot twist
[Laughter]
no no no no see i don't think i would be
uh
good with babies i've always felt that
i'm just not a maternal person
i mean i was that is so wrong assistant
you're probably the most
emotional connected huge thing what she
said
news you started crying i think i've
just been very emotional these days
maybe
something's in retrograde i cried you
guys that's another thing i've been
crying
a lot you have been a lot so when this
guy goes
he hands me a baby his baby and
despite my hands being so big there's no
way i could actually drop it
but i just i it got all tense and i got
nervous and i felt a panic attack coming
on and
yeah you know you you think that the
baby is one of those babies that can't
hold its head up that freaks me out
when the baby is all scared
loosey-goosey
hold a kid push a kid out what's going
to go on downstairs afterwards
you know what's funny mom mentioned her
pregnancy cravings the other day
do you think you didn't my pregnancy
cravings have such a theory
that whatever mom was craving while she
was pregnant with each of us is what we
like now
okay so explain me this yeah why am i
addicted to
soup crackers saltines you are obsessed
with saltines they have a box today but
they're soup crackers
are they really yes who likes that
me yeah that was her craving and then
with scarlett she ate
cheerios and scotland has cheerios every
day what was yours probably
i don't know cauliflower i know all my
mom told me was that she gained 60
pounds
she's oh okay okay so um
i thought it was kind of weird how you
already have a list of baby names on it
i don't think that's weird at all
i see a name i hear a name and i go okay
would i name my kid that i threw out the
names
at the lunch and everyone loved them i
think you'd be so
i don't know you said you wanted to
borrow one of them i mean yeah you're
prepared i am very ready to go and if i
get knocked up first
knock on wood do you think you're gonna
be a hard mom or you think you're gonna
be
an easy going mom i think i'm gonna be
the devil
because if my kid turns out anything
like me
oh my god what are you talking about
you're a good kid sophia
i was a good kid but i was
looking back on my personality as a
child it's so concerning
it's so concerning a child yes should we
just get it i know we've talked about
the weird things that we did
when we were maybe in high school middle
school but take it even younger than
that
i was so weird oh my god i think
if our kid turned out the way that we
turned out when we were growing up
they would definitely not be the cool
kid we were not cool at all
for example oh i don't even know where
to start i guess the first thing that
comes to my head
one thing i did
was i would collect roly-polies
those little bugs and i ate them sophia
you ate insects sophia do you hate
roly-polies
if my [ __ ] baby eats a roly-poly i'm
disowning you and i did that oh
that's nasty okay well make me feel
better did you do anything weird
at all all right let me think let me
think um
what what help me out okay i don't know
why i did this this makes
absolutely no sense but you know when
you use an eraser like one of those big
erasers to
erase a pencil i know how to use an
eraser yeah so i had a very intricate
uh pencil box that like kind of opened
up like
layers and there's little boxes okay so
i used to collect all the
eraser shavings in like second grade and
put them in a box
see that is what i'm saying why did i
collect a razor shape
i consider that a collection i'll do you
one better yeah what
i would
i just thought of another one i would
get snails and put them in my locker
and let them crawl around like it was a
sanctuary
are you kidding you're building a little
snail i'm getting chills that's
disgusting
all right that's not as bad as i used to
uh find rocks around campus
just like little rocks yeah it's like
small rocks and put in my pocket
so by the end of the day i'd have like
rocks stuffed in my pockets
but then i thought that if i ever got
lost on campus
i don't know how i'd do that i left like
rock trails everywhere oh my god
so i would like walk my way back to
class using my rock trail
what was just in case you go
your shorts with um rocks i stuffed my
bra with
literal toilet rolls this is why we
didn't have friends toilet rolls
we had spongebob square boobs because it
was literally a toilet roll
favorite story about you i love the fact
that when sistine was younger
um she always always asked my mom for
flavor blast
uh gold flip goldfish i can't even say
the word flavor blast goldfish
uh and i don't know if you know what
that is it's great great goldfish but
she would ask for bags and bags of it
and we can
get into a room and we found all these
random pokemon cards let me tell you
something
i was a little hustler back in the day
yeah this is so weird too
like i was basically a little dealer in
the making
i would go to kids yeah right and i
would say
meet me behind the greenhouse at recess
i was very young
right i would go these guys would come
meet me right scary so scary i'd give
them
boxes of goldfish for their pokemon
cards and i would just keep trading and
trading and trading with kids and that
ended up getting like
insane things that started with goldfish
and then i'd get like some grandpa's
wars coins like just
so cool stuff you would fail your
spelling test but you were focused on
dealing pokemon cards which you had
absolutely no idea how to use
no i just had no idea you just got all
of them that would have been smart to
keep them because i heard that's just a
big
thing right now so that's the problem
would you
i knowing what i know now would you let
your kid just be that way or would you
go you know
maybe try not to be as i'll tell you the
final
yeah if i did this next thing
and i was mom and my daughter did this
i would i would say i'll see you in
court
i go to suburban you'll see my lawyer
you're here you're gonna hear from my
attorney i'm going to replace him i
don't know why jennifer didn't say there
must be something wrong with her
i go to subway for years yeah you did do
you want to know my order
what i'd get a footlong
right but yeah toasted right some cheese
some mayo extra mayo that's it
yeah like a mayonnaise sandwich [ __ ]
ew you're just so
freaked out i'll see you in court
who does by the way that makes no sense
what is you'll see me in court i have to
do with anything i don't know i just
said
i don't know do you understand how
disgust
cheese and mayo sandwich who am i why
didn't mom say sweetie put some meat in
there we need to have kids together so
then we can make sure
our kids aren't as weird because our oh
my god even talents show [ __ ]
i remember my talent show i brought a
basketball on stage
just myself in a basketball and i sang
the song from like mike
like mike yeah i just dribbled
basketball is my favorite sport i like
the way we dribble up and down
we can't make the point of this
conversation is we cannot make offspring
yes they turn out anything like us maybe
that's why i saw that kid i'm like i
know i shouldn't have one
but i want it now that i can't have it
yeah let's not do that
but we should have chris medina let us
know oh god because i feel like it's
probably you better get pregnant first
you can do the trouble
okay so moving on i am so shocked that
not enough people do this because every
time i talk to someone about this they
have no idea what i'm saying or they say
it's completely genius because
yeah i bought glasses i'm really smart
now
i don't know if anyone out there does
this but
if you are not using your close friends
feature on instagram
strategically are you doing
oh yeah we're getting into girl talk now
i gotta transition into this because
it's kind of
frustrating all right so this is also
gonna be a new segment i think we're
gonna call it girl talk because
everyone likes when we kind of share a
little secret by the way
by the way i think mike i was about to
out our cousin
say um about his girlfriend seeing him
on
linkedin and i think that was fully from
us
his ex-girlfriend so we keep giving
really great advice
great stalking advice but it's coming
back to hurt our family members like our
cousin for example
because apparently his ex is using our
stocking methods from the show to stalk
our cousin
oh god i'm so sorry cousin i know yeah
so we're i think we should just keep
that going
well let me let me continue the close
friends feature
and the fact that you don't even use
this correctly just astonishes me
well you're genius because you did this
early i'll explain why we're messing
this up
i've been doing this for years i started
with the finster before close friends
was even a thing
yeah i strategically depending on the
picture
will edit the list every time i know you
might think that sounds crazy
but it's just a sneaky way to thirst
trap someone get someone's attention
fair you know for example doesn't have
to be sexual
if i tell my girlfriend oh definitely
gonna out myself they're gonna kill me
i go oh i am so busy i can't make this
lunch
i am shooting the podcast right yeah
i will upload on my close friends at the
podcast studio and she will be the only
one i'm going to close friends
so she sees oh she's not lying that she
thinks
and she can't see who else is at it so
for all she knows i have 30 people on my
close friends i'll give you another
example i
never thought of that one every time i
post a really cute
a bathing suit picture maybe something a
little bit like hehe
all my close friends you best believe
anyone that i've come into contact with
kissing wise dating wise
is on that list x is 100 percent just
then
i can see which x looked at it all that
stuff
we said just those guys yeah but wait
this the problem though you've told me
one time to do that you're like adam on
it
it's been two years i can't just
randomly add a guy i went out with i
would
for some reason want to bring back into
my life you gotta sprinkle in
you gotta plant some seeds before don't
you think it's a little weird if i like
the day i post him or have him come on
my close friend's list
this is what i would recommend this is
what i would recommend you start by
liking
his photo every other photo so then he
goes oh okay she's sort of been on my
instagram maybe i'm not muted anymore
and then you start viewing a story and
then after about a week or two of that
then you adam
because you guys are homies now you're
close friends you're liking his stuff no
big deal
yeah i'm telling you close friends
if you guys aren't using it correctly
what the [ __ ] are you doing also
another way i like to use the close
friends feature is
if i have a guy that i want him to feel
like special
you know and i'm talking to him and
maybe we have an inside joke
and i want to flirt subtly and make him
feel
like he has my attention yeah i will
literally just post our inside joke so
then he responds like oh my god
that's so you're saying you're kidding
but he's the only one on it that's
that's that's like he thinks i'm posting
it to all our friends but only we know
the little secret like no it's just him
on it
that's that's kind of toxic she said my
glasses were
bad she's back to wearing them because
she feels smart again
glasses back on by the way the fact that
you just said toxic is so funny
wait you've been on the train right now
is that bad
that i've been saying this and no one's
getting on board except you
i just said like i've been saying such a
good idea i said i've been bored
i feel like this whole obviously the
past two years like everyone hasn't been
really been able to do too much or a
year and a half whatever
and i said i really want like everyone
keeps saying hot girl summer i keep
saying toxic girl summer it's so funny
why is i was saying hot girl summer i
want like some [ __ ] to go down
i want to say three episodes ago we
called it hot girl summer and how we're
having a hot girl summer
and now we're totally doing the
opportunity no [ __ ] what we said ignore
that we're doing talk
toxic girl summer oh we're ready to just
like
cause a menace i want to be at a club
okay i see my ex over there
i'm talking to a new guy but at the same
time i'm on my phone
texting someone i'm also interested
toxic girl summer
drinking tequila all right toxic girl
summer
you know what the best thing is though
when you're at a club with um and
i do this every time this is the best
advice jennifer our mom has ever given
us
yeah always leave the house like you're
gonna run into someone you know yeah so
i never leave looking heinous and every
time i do i end up seeing someone i know
that is so true but it's always been a
dream just to
have one of those [ __ ] movie moments
and you're in a club and it's all
slow-mo and then you don't see anyone in
the crowd because it's just a sea of
people right
yeah do you have the music going on in
your head yeah give me a little beat
we're in the club right and it's just me
and i lock eyes with my ex across the
room i'm like oh
[ __ ] here we go feeling a little tipsy
like wouldn't that just be the best
that's the toxic energy i'm talking
about that is the toxic energy i'm
talking about so are you trying to get
back with your ex
no but i want to also make him think
we're getting back together why are we
on the same page people like you want
them to just
want you that's like what i want i think
being back in l.a we just
love the drama well no one see i think
this is the problem
no have we've been in a hole no one has
seen us
except through our podcast for the last
i don't know six months
so we're back i'm gonna quote something
you said oh
the other night can i say you said
i kind of wan
you're so toxic wait literally this is
the first night out in l.a
since being back and you said i hope
there's drama tonight
because every time you go out with drama
it makes it so much better
i know i'm like i either i'm involved in
it
okay i'm not involved in it and i just
like
light the fire walk away okay i'm gonna
ask a question yeah
i sometimes feel like this is the best
way to sort of open that door to an ex
when it's their birthday now i always
get
mixed reviews on this do you text your
ex on their birthday if you're trying to
sort of
reopen them ryan brought this up to us
because he was like as a guy
it's actually we should probably have
ryan on soon since he's a guy and he'd
bring his guy perspective
in but he was asking even us we were
trying to answer this
is it good to text your ex on what are
vice versa i think
she's sitting back yes depending
on the situation but also the duration
so let's just say it's been two years
you guys
ended amicably there's no reason
to not just say happy birthday i don't
think it's about if they're single
but if they're not if they're not single
it's been two years and it ended shitty
who you you forget their name in your
head they just never existed you're
telling me they're shouldn't
you oh you're considering this let's ask
the only dude in the room
yes or no texting your next on a
birthday absolutely not
say wait why absolutely not it's hurtful
oh no that's toxic girl summer
who are we we gotta know we gotta yes we
gotta
we're unwaxed sorry but that's actually
that's fair point because oh god if you
do text your ex on their birthday say
happy birthday
it brings feelings back up it does it
does even when i get a text even if i
don't care about them anymore and this
can be an x that you actually dated for
a long time or this can be an x that you
just had like
a fling with whatever it's still you
can't just let me ask the question what
if
they've sort of been waiting for an
opportunity to reach out and you've been
hearing from other people
like what if you're both sort of just
expecting it you know
do you still do it as she just closed
the door entirely
um i know it's almost like
what's in the past just leave it in the
past but yeah i'm bored
i'm bored well okay i know people are
probably thinking that we're like
crazy they're like these girls are
really toxic
here's the thing 22 years of being a
good angel i'm tired i'm just grandpa
she's
tired of eating roller pulleys i'm proud
of this grandpa i'm having no voice
no but you know what actually i'm gonna
add on to this so we can have a
ending on a positive note because you
know cece and i do say we love the drama
we do
yeah we do i mean we don't always cause
it but we just like we just like to have
things going on but
no i'll tell you what it is we don't
like the drama we like to wake up the
next morning hungover and say i like
oh my god what just happened listen to
this story yeah so
i think that also adding on to a
positive point of toxic girl summary if
you want to make it less toxic
why is cut out this 2020 one is maybe
also decide that i want to
like cut off toxic people in my life too
like boyfriend-wise different story
that's good
that's a part of it there's history it's
history and you know it's fun
but i think when it comes to friends
and stuff like that we've just had like
a realization with that
and i think we're so much more it's hard
i keep messing with my mic i don't know
why it's really hard to cut off a friend
though
yeah like the way i do it is not great
i've been very into just
ghosting people because i think before i
felt so guilty for
ignoring a text or if someone texted me
and i really did not
want to answer them or they did
something to me in the past i always
felt like i owed them an explanation
right it's like you really don't no you
really don't owe anyone an explanation
unless
it's that bad see that's that toxic that
we're not being honest
maybe we give terrible advice on this
podcast
we actually don't help anyone we told
people to find their ex on yelp and see
if they complain i feel like this is
just
we're entertaining that's all that's all
that's all it is should we um transition
into another segment of my favorite
segment
yeah bedtime stories oh yeah
[Music]
okay here it goes um so as you guys know
bedtime stories
is just a story that's happened to us
either in the past or recent
and you guys got it we have a super
recent story super recent story
but one time we read one of your bedtime
stories on the show
so if you want to submit your bedtime
story for us to read on the show
either respond to our dm
on instagram our email on our instagram
bio
or where else can they find us that's
pretty much it just
you guys we read everything message us
yeah you know and we'll find it
sophia this might be my favorite story
do you want to kick it off since you
kind of got me into the situation this
happened a month ago
it was a shitty situation no pun
intended
yeah here we go i feel like we talk
about [ __ ]
okay that's fine so this is when we were
in florida
my mom is super busy she goes girls you
got to bring
the dogs to the groomers right and three
crabapoos that act like crackheads you
can't really take them with one person
you need to have two people in the car
there's just a lot to handle
so i said sophia can you come pick up
the dogs because i already dropped them
off can you come help me pick up the
dogs
and i look at sophia she's um
glistening with fake tan uh hair in a
hair mask and
in a bathrobe no shoes and she goes i'm
not an acne cream an acting cream and
she goes i'm not coming i said looking
like that i don't blame you but you
don't have to get out of the car
the steam was when she says asking me
she was like no sophia i need your help
get in the car i'm like i really can't
see you
please you didn't even have to get out
of the car right no so scene tells me
i'll drive park you stay in the car and
then when the dogs come back in the car
after the groomers
just watch them hold them and make sure
they're not running around so
sophia a bathrobe yeah messy bun
no shoes yeah and guys when i say dogs
we mean three
cavaliers a lot that's not just one one
dog's easy
three of them i go into the store the
groomers go into the groomers
i pick up the dogs and i'm walking them
across the street back to the car
and my car is parked across the street
across the street right yeah
and for some reason the street is you
know
always empty but always empty god just
loved us at this moment and thought
let's make it very popular at this time
there were cars on both
sides trying to cross and they let me
jaywalk i was like great there were
people on the sidewalks there was at
least 10 witnesses
oh yeah to this instance i'm walking the
dogs across the street i say thank you
cars let you know stopping for me thank
you
and i'm pulling one of the dogs and
she's not walking and i turn around
winnie and one of the [ __ ] dogs
starts having not just
diarrhea no they just had a full-blown
bridesmaid
moment explosion that movie shooting out
and i know you're like oh my god that
sounds so stupid no no
you guys she was pulling her as she was
going to the bathroom
and so sistine's stuck in the middle of
the street there are eight cars
in both ways trying to get across this
thing standing with this dog that's
shitty
on the road at least 10 feet of [ __ ]
trail oh yeah
and not only that sistine i hear from
outside going
sofia help i'm freaking out so she
leaves winnie
in the middle of the street to get to
have me grab her while she grabs the
other two
i ditched the dog i jump out in my robe
no shoes
orange you see she's actually crazy
and grab the dog i'm holding it up i
look to the side of the car
and these two boys are filming i look in
front of me someone else is filming
i'm about to get on some type of i want
you guys to have this image in your head
there's a dog [ __ ] her brains on
somebody else's still going to
shoeless in a bathrobe and at 3 p.m by
the way
yeah 3 p.m in the afternoon just holding
a dog that is still [ __ ] as she's
holding it
there are cars but i have a mask on
there are cars that are so disgusted and
what they're seeing
they're honking and they're actually
going around the [ __ ] because it was
that smelly like it was so bad right
so i shoved the other oh no these guys
were like laughing there was a like
like thinking i looked hot so until we
started to get some
some neighbors come out of their houses
this was a whole ordeal this is a huge
we started getting some neighbors just
took a good like if a
count to a minute like a minute 60
seconds i would say it was no at least
three minute or dude do you think so 100
percent in my life because then i had to
deal with her
she didn't stop for some reason i don't
know why she was like a fire hose this
day
i get some some sassy neighbors come out
of their house yeah
and she's looking at me like is that
poop
is your dog pooping and i said no it's
pee
if she's peeing because she goes i'm
gonna find you
because it's a 500 dollar fine if you
don't pick up your dog's poop it's not
no she didn't just want to add more fuel
to the fire that's already going on
yeah like you can see we are struggling
yes
there's also the other two dogs are
jetting off somewhere cesium couldn't
handle them
i'm whole but see it just goes back to
the simple task of picking up your dog
at the groomers
turns into an absolute [ __ ] show
yeah it really did so i had to sit with
um
the dog diarrhea in her lap on the way
home yeah oh yeah yeah my bathrobe is
gone destroyed yeah it's just a great
time it was a lot of fun
um i don't think we can ever go back and
i really hope
someone can send me that video i hope
you
i hope you don't and i would love to see
that footage you in the middle of a
street
with in broad daylight with a dog that's
pooping and you're in a bathrobe and no
shoes you look like a crazy person i
looked like a crazy person that's so
funny though oh
god what are you gonna do you know
that was our bedtime story remember by
the way i feel like people
it's like since we've been doing these
bedtime stories situations that are way
more chaotic than they should be
have been happening and i don't know if
you guys are causing this or people are
praying for us to get into
horrible situations but i kind of love
when we do
because then we can talk about it on the
show oh yeah that's not only that
um remember how i talked about the story
about my nails falling off
yes oh yeah yeah he brought that up
so you guys i'm exposing myself i told
everyone that um i wore fake nails and
they're falling off all over the food
and yeah
you guys know every time that we do
bring up a story on the show about
a guy or a recent date we went on there
has not been a time where they haven't
questioned us
oh you shared it on the podcast oh was
that about me
yeah and you know what even said he was
things we do for you guys these micro
lies i'm like hmm
he said what micro you guys are like
what are you who are you really
oh god he's going to listen to this
screw it nice
that was nice yeah
microlife micro life i've never heard
that before i know
are you micro liar am i mike am i a mega
liar then like what does that even mean
i mean
you think i want to tell people that i
wore sticky nails from target and they
were falling out yeah but we do it for
the
content we do it for the content we do
it for you guys
yeah looping back to you guys we are
going to jump into our
unsolicited advice segment sophia why
don't you tell them
how they can submit their questions same
thing as always
no sophia go to the apple podcast
facebook oh i was like
god we're so mad at right now go to the
apple podcast page
give us that five star and in the
comments and
review section please just ask your
question there and we
that's the only way we're going to read
it the first question is you have both
dealt with hate in the past
what was some of the worst and how did
you handle it
and when i read this question my brain
went to the first the first thing i just
i already knew a very bad instance for
me
do you remember i i went into an
audition
an acting audition maybe a year ago yeah
a year and a half ago
and i go into this audition and i
didn't know the etiquette when you are
doing
an audition in the acting world you're
not really supposed to make friends with
the people working the casting directors
you're not really supposed to talk to
them you're sort of just supposed to get
in there and do your job and whatever
me thinking i'm just going to sell
myself on them and then maybe they'll
think i'm a good actor
that's how i sort of remember so i go in
i do my audition do i think i got it
no but do i think it was terrible no i
thought i did
an okay to good job right
i get a call from my agent my old agent
and i get a call at 8 in the morning and
she calls to tell me normally when you
get a call at 8 a.m
it's good news you got the part yeah
agents don't call it 8 in the morning
and i answer and i go hello thinking
here we go big break and
she goes you know how do you think you
did and i said i think i did good and
blah blah blah
and she goes interesting because the
only notes
that this casting director left for you
was stupid and i go what and she goes
yeah those are the only notes and i go
well what was stupid me or or the
audition like what did she say and she
goes
i didn't ask i go okay
what a mature person i know so anyway
there's so much more to the story but
how i dealt with that
was my mom and dad basically had to talk
me out of this dark hole and there
because i felt so bad about myself i was
crying
i felt like an idiot and i don't really
know why they would just say i was
stupid or anything like that but
my mom what she helped me with is she
said write this person's name down
and write down what you want to
accomplish because
of how this person made you feel so
that's what i did i wrote down the
woman's name
and then i wrote down my goal that is
going to make me stronger because of it
and time told the truth and it happened
right
so it kind of like in a weird way just
sort of shifting
your your negative energy or the way you
felt and turning it into something
positive
that's a no that's a really good story
especially when it comes to
the entertainment world in the work
field even just getting rejected at
anything
yeah exactly and my story for hate is i
would say more so
with people like in college and i
remember this one story and
oh my god it was my freshman year or
sophomore year i can't remember
and we had just gone the golden globe
miss golden globe
thing right and i was sitting in the
room and it was with eight girls and
some of them were my sorority
some of them were not and i literally
just had
found out and i told one of the girls
there and apparently it kind of like
obviously
circulated a little bit and one of the
girls sat in front of everyone
you know you only got that because of
who your dad is just like most things in
your life
and in the future you won't have to work
that hard at anything yeah and she goes
i promise you
you're so lucky and
i remember in that moment going
you know yeah i understand that
there are situations and things that we
will
get just because or at least no we'll
get
more notice because of who our dad is
and i'll never
ever fault that like i'm so proud of
where did you say anything to her um so
i didn't at first
i really was kind of i was more you know
when you're in this situation you don't
know what to say
i remember i didn't know what to say so
i left it then
i came back around later on like the two
days later we're all kind of sitting
there it was a bigger group of girls
um and now what did i say i said kind of
like
i was like you know i wanted to bring up
what you said yesterday and that was
unbelievably [ __ ] of you because a lot
of things that i do in life
i actually work hard for and karma's a
[ __ ]
so i just like kind of do that so i kind
of like said something like that
but i stuck up for myself and i was like
and i kind of didn't need to prove
anything to her but
in my head and this is just like
negative self-talk
what i told myself is because of that
[ __ ] comment from her i'm going to
work
10 times as hard and i don't need people
to tell me that i deserved it because i
got on my own i want to know that i got
it on my own i don't need validation
from people
because everyone opinions are like
[ __ ] everyone has them oh
and everyone will yeah and so things
that we do in life i can't
wait for people to validate me and so
that's kind of how i thought i was like
look she's obviously from a dark place
and
i'm not gonna let her drag me down so
i'm gonna keep doing idea which is be
positive
work as hard as i can and i mean to be
honest
you know there's a lot of good things
coming it's sort of the same but
different it's almost like you work
harder because my bad habit is i
sometimes try to prove people wrong it's
my favorite pastime i love proving
people wrong but it shouldn't be the
driving force to why i want success
but i think it should be some of it and
you know in the end
if anyone gives you hate obviously
there's something going on with them
in their own personal lives and their
own insecurities so don't take it
personally
it's not worth it and just keep doing
you and be the best you
retweet sophia thank you all right the
second question is
um i don't drink because i get migraines
but i feel like drinking is a huge part
of dating any advice
other questions about dealing with
migraines okay so i picked this question
out because
you get a lot of migraines and there
were a lot of questions regarding
migraines because you've talked about
your experience on it
i'll just chip in a little bit in the
beginning about social drinking dating
drinking i think
i support it i think it takes the edge
off and i think is there a way that
you can do it sophia that you've
experienced that it doesn't actually
it's so funny because
i actually someone brought this up i
forgot who it was on instagram
and they were saying how there was this
societal pressure
that when you go on a date you always
have to drink or you have to have a
glass
of wine and i mean for me i'm just
kidding i do
i need to take the edge off um and i
don't have it as bad where i can get my
i get migraines from
alcohol i get migraines just from stress
a lot and so i'll get them once a month
i'm very very
uh assisting hates being around me from
that but i realize
it it really just depends on the person
you stay hydrated
you have to manage your anxiety and calm
down
we'll cut the drinking out how do you
deal with migraines well that's what it
is you
lower your stress you stay hydrated try
to reduce caffeine
um it smells terrible i mean you kind of
can find the medication that works for
you
you know also dope you can do botox so
if you want to get into that train
you know what's kind of funny is when
she said i like
there's a pressure to drink if you don't
want to drink on a date don't do it
sometimes
i go on dates with people and i'm really
not that nervous for it and i feel like
he's waiting there or he's not pushing
anything i mean honestly like no one's
ever forced me to have a drink like
i can let's put a gun into my head
inside if you don't get this
cocktail with tahini around the rim i'm
gonna
no it's i but i feel like if you're not
in the mood and you're driving
and you're just there to get to know
someone don't do it yeah but
they're gonna look at you or avoid it
and just do a a lunch or a coffee date i
understand that that sometimes you can
feel like oh the person's going to feel
uncomfortable having a drink but just
make it known like it does not matter to
you you're not judging them who cares
like who cares if someone has a drink or
not like i just i agree yeah
thank you i agree to an extent i like my
cocktails oh no no
i like my cocktail i'm not gonna do this
let's stay on brand with toxic girl
summer let's stay on brand oh yeah
we had the toxic bodies tequila tequila
that's toxic the last one i thought was
funny i don't think you are prepared for
this one
no what's your best pickup line to a guy
do you have one or maybe just your your
go-to
flirting tip i actually was flirting
with someone the other day and i don't
think this was a good flirting technique
but i
i think i scared him because i said we
should do a vegas trip and he's like
yeah and i go yeah i'll be really funny
let's go meet elvis and get in the
chapel
oh you said let's get hitched basically
i didn't mean to i was kind of did you
also say you want to
get pregnant with him as well like why
would you do that i feel like it was
along the lines since i saw that baby it
depends a lot of guys would probably be
into it
but then i also said and then i quickly
he kind of looked at me weird so i said
no no we get a divorce after and it'd
just be a funny story
for the podcast it was a really really
stressful oh so your line is let's go to
vegas and get him no that's not but i
said i said that line i thought that was
going to be funny but if he didn't find
that funny it didn't come off well no
come on no what's your pickup line um
mine the problem with la guys is they'll
stare at you but they won't come up to
you
that's that's what i hate about los
angeles so it's like do i either have
something in my teeth do you want to
come say hi like what are you looking at
right so if a guy is staring at me and i
catch him staring at me i'll call over
and i'll say
i see you peeking but she ain't speaking
what's that about
and typically it works
speaking to 50 success right with that
one either they just turn around going
why would she just have that ready to go
right what the hell
and the other time they think it's funny
they'll come up to me so
that's a use it you're welcome i thought
you were gonna say if a guy is staring
at you just stare back and start barking
or something like that why would that
bring someone over no i mean
barking you see a guy looking at you
checking you out
wow it's looking weird yeah but
so don't use my line i like your line i
think that would work thanks it will
okay i think we should wrap up the show
yeah i could sit for another two hours
with you guys
um okay just sophia can you uh tell me
how to
find the socials and everything i keep
forgetting how to do it okay if you guys
want to find us on
more chipper oh okay
i drawing tripper okay thank you guys so
much for listening to this week's
episode we cannot wait to see you back
next week and maybe we'll have a guest
since we love our little train we've
been having with gus
so if you want to find us go to unwax
podcast on instagram we have a twitter
that i barely run so you probably don't
find us on twitter
we also have an email it's unwaxed
podcast gmail.com
and our tick tock and we have a tick
tock that we're also really bad at
running we're really bad at writing but
it's
not our best it has no flow no flow but
we're doing our best okay we love you
we'll see you next tuesday
bye guys from all of us here at the show
thanks for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts spotify
follow your hosts at sophia stallone and
at sistine stallone
and be sure to follow the show at
unwaxed podcast we'll see you next week